ils seront trois à représenter les
yvelines lors des jeux paralympiques à
tokyo qui débute le 24 août prochain
parmi eux le nageur axel portal 19 ans
il s'entraîne à saint-germain-en-laye
depuis ses 7 ans il a décroché son
ticket pour tokyo en 2019 après avoir
remporté deux médailles lors des
championnats du monde il débutera la
compétition dès le 25 route elle aussi a
décroché son ticket pour tokyo grâce à
ses bons résultats sur les courts de
tennis charlotte verband qui
s'entraînent à voisins le bretonneux va
disputer ses premiers jeux paralympiques
à 29 ans j'ai vraiment très content très
content de pouvoir y aller de vivre
cette expérience et
de partir avec toute cette équipe de
france donc non non juste trop contente
de partir là je m'entraîne à barcelone
et je me prépare bien physiquement
mentalement l'objectif vraiment faim ce
serait de passer un deux trois tours si
je peux mais mais je veux pas être
surréalisme en plus je me dis pas que je
vais décrocher une médaille à ces jeux
je pense que voilà des possibles après
première fois que le para badminton
entre aux jeux paralympiques et c'est
aussi une première fois pour l'andrésien
merrill look est à 23 ans celui qui
avait misé plus tôt sur les jeux à paris
en 2024 a gagné sa sélection il ya
quelques semaines à peine je suis trop
content parce que j'étais le dernier
sélectionnés de l'équipe j'ai déjà
appris ça on va dire même pas un mois
avant de partir donc ça fait quoi ça
fait deux semaines que je n'ai appris
alors que tout le monde le savait gt gt
à l'aéroport pour partir en stage et il
ya ma coach qui m'appelle fait écoute je
pense que tu vas faire partie de
l'aventuré l'âge quand ça j'ai crié et
j'étais tellement content et c'est
l'histoire malheureuse de ces jeux
cécile sabouraud aurait dû prendre le
départ pour tokyo mais la parra
triathlète a été victime d'un accident
lors de sa préparation le 30 juillet
dernier et au creps de vichy lors d'un
de mes entraînements vélo j'ai été
renversée par un camion benne et il a
pris la fuite le choc a été violent je
suis très déçu de pas pouvoir aller à
tokyo mais tellement contente d'être là
parce que le choc était tellement
violent donc je suis un peu entre les
deux mais bon je sais que la vie s'est
fait de hauts et de bas et je me dis que
bah j'ai disputé bien bas là ça a été
dur expo que remonter pour cette 16e
édition des jeux paralympiques no3
yvelinois compte bien nous faire rêver
poursuivre leur parc rendez vous du 24
août au 5 septembre prochain